SPEAKER: Your app's
performance is
crucial to your user's happiness
and your app's success.
An internal study of
reviews on Google Play
found that half of
one star reviews
mentions stability or crashes.
By identifying and fixing
issues and bad behaviors,
you could see happier
users and better ratings,
which will also improve
your app's discoverability.
Introducing Android Vitals.
Android Vitals in
the Play Console
gives you new data
so you can understand
your app's stability,
battery usage,
and render time on real devices.
Stability.
Android Vitals include
two bad behaviors relating
to stability, application
not responding errors,
or ANRs, and crashes.
ANRs occur when the
application freezes
and stops responding
to user input for more
than five seconds.
This is usually
caused by deadlocks,
slowness in UI threads
or background processes.
When your app crashes, it can
be a frustrating experience
for the user, impacting
retention and leading
to bad reviews.
The crash rate will
show you the percentage
of users experiencing
crashes in your app.
One way to address
stability issues
is to run pre-launch
reports, which
will test your alpha or beta
app on physical devices,
so you can identify and fix
issues before you launch.
Battery.
Well-behaved apps
don't consume battery
by keeping the device radio
and CPU on unnecessarily.
Android Vitals lets
you see the metrics
for two common causes of battery
drain, wake ups and wake locks.
Wake ups are caused by
alarms performing time
based operations that prevent
an idle device from sleeping.
Wake locks are when
the app has your device
working so hard it
won't allow it to sleep.
For better battery life, you
can use job scheduling APIs
to schedule asynchronous
tasks and specify conditions
to maximize efficiency.
This is suitable for small
tasks like clearing a cache
and for large ones like syncing
a database to the cloud.
Render time.
The speed at which
your app renders
impacts user perception
of your app performance.
Slow render time or frozen
frames lead to bad reviews.
Apps that have a render
time of 16 milliseconds
or reach 60 frames
per second produce
a silky smooth experience
for your users.
This is the rate at which users
can perceive smooth motion
within your app.
Therefore, Android
Vitals lets you
see what percentage of users
experienced more than 50%
of frames with a render time of
greater than 16 milliseconds,
so you can provide a smooth
experience across all devices.
Anything greater than a render
time of 700 milliseconds
is considered a frozen
frame, and at this rate,
users consider an app
to be unresponsive.
Avoid slow render
times or frozen frames
by using frame metrics
APIs to measure
per interaction frame
render times for devices
during production.
Find out about other
features in the Play Console
and get tips to grow your app or
game business with the Playbook
App available on Google Play.